thank you okay I'd like you draw this
you draw this for me as best as you can
doesn't have to be a work of art you're
about to see how bad mine will be volume
and capacity now you might recall
actually just going to pinch this you
might recall I asked you to fill out
I asked you to feel at a table earlier
like a few a few couple weeks ago
actually which had all kinds of
measurements of different kinds of units
right I do you remember what's the
difference basically volume and capacity
they're very very similar to each other
so very close so that's capacity right
so let's submit that so that's how much
stuff you can fit inside an object right
so most of you probably recognize the
capacity of this is to lead so envision
capacity in liters
whereas volume is the number of the
amount of stuff that actually makes up
an object and this can be quite
different so this is the stuff that
makes up the object it's the space that
the object takes up okay so the
important relationship that connects
these two together is that one cubic
centimeter
I'd love you to actually draw we've done
this before I'd love you to draw cubic
centimeter to scale on your page right
so most of you have a five millimeter
grid there so you want to pick out like
one centimeter by 1 centimeter would
look like that right and then you can go
ahead and you can turn that into a prism
this one cubic centimeter is exactly
equal to we define it to be equal to one
milliliter okay which we abbreviate it
to Neils
but it's worth commenting but that is
milli
is later okay so therefore how many
milliliters are in this true liter
bottle think about it figure out what
milli means yeah very good sir a mili
liter is one thousandth of a liter and
if you're two leaves in you there must
be two thousand of them okay so
therefore this thing here right if we
say it's got two thousand then what must
its volumes debate not a complicated
question yeah Chris new leaders hold on
this is I've already got a capacity what
will the volume be 2000 cubic
centimeters now interestingly just
before this track I got um I planted
someone to do some measurements for me
can you tell me what the measurements
are that you actually measured out do
you haven't met 29 so this thing here
you could put onto your diagram now is
29 centimeters and is a square base is a
square base yes this is I'll expand so
you guys your fleet roughly I mean I
know it's curvy yeah so here on the
bottom if we were to imagine I know it's
not but if we were to imagine that it
was like a prison cuz mostly a prison
right and this is nine by nine what's
the area down here that's square nine
times 981 square centimeters nine times
nine okay now you might have a
calculator within easy reach there
can someone tell me about 29 times 81
one two three four nine so keep in mind
we estimated all that yeah cuz look this
is not a perfect rectangular prism is it
right it's got all kinds of curvy bits
and even got like a hole through it okay
so let me cut out how much should we cut
out how much cut out if this is what
gives me two ladies yeah I must be
missing 249 cubic sorry that should be a
three cubic centimeters yeah
so that's accounted for by the fact that
it's kind of rounded it's kind of round
it and then you've got bits kind of it
so we have a handle does that make sense
but that's really well there is two
capacity right there are some
conversions you can do put this super
basic they're even more basic than the
ones you already know so maybe you want
to throw one of these for me you can put
in leaders so we already know if we want
to go from mills to leaders right I have
two thousand bills in you so what do I
have to do to this number to turn it
into a number of leaders do I multiply
divide I divide because I'm going from a
literal unit to a big one
what about you got another step to get
from ladies to kilo liters whoa
if I was going directly I would go a
million I remember kilo me three a
thousand right so there are three zero
three zeros all wrong with that and of
course in the opposite direction I have
to multiply instead of device okay now
there is one more across the end here if
you want if you cut space there it's not
that common but its capital M rather
than this will end very very different a
window is sales for Big O and again it's
a thousand